welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka cora the
explorer
and this video we're breaking down the
penultimate episode of agents of shield
the show is heading towards a big finale
and throughout this we'll be going over
our thoughts and theories on the entry
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything rune
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
video and make sure you subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss our breakdown
on the show's ending
anyway with all out the way huge thank
you for clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown of
episode 11.
okay so we pick up with daisy watching
malik take simmons and deke to parts
unknown in the search for fits
the kidnappers have gone stratospheric
and luckily for the agents
cora has just been brought into the base
to interrogate
daisy slams her against the wall upon
seeing her
and after mack makes her put a half
sister down she states that she's just
here to help
turns out everyone wants to be an agent
these days
and she talks about how things have
changed and her goals for the future
the episode is titled brand new day and
she very much hammers home the notion
that the timeline has changed far too
much to ever go back to normal
cora insists that malik actually wishes
to use what he knows of the future
to change things for humanity's
betterment and that they want to live in
their hashtag
best life i don't know how you can kill
people for the best outcome
but shield two have murdered many in
order to protect the world
now at this point the show is existing
firmly in the multi-worlds way of
thinking
this david deutsch theory on time travel
states that
if we were to go back to the past we
would instead be creating branched
realities that would only alter things
in our present
and that the prior past we experienced
would head off in its own direction
without us
this was seen in endgame but it's also
used here to mean that daisy's mother
can die before she's born without her
vanishing from existence
that's a theory that's typically known
as the grandfather paradox
which the show clearly isn't operating
with and
if you want to see me talk about this
more in depth then make sure you check
out our new umbrella academy's timeline
video
which goes over all the main time travel
theories in more detail
now it turns out that cora has a list of
30 people
who if she kills will allegedly save
thousands of lives
we'll discuss this later but it's
something definitely to bear in mind
now we have seen notions of this before
and when project insight was about to
launch in the 70s
there were notable agents of shield
members on it and also bruce banner
i'm actually also leaning in more with
the idea that the timeline is completely
ruined at this point
and that they should just kill whoever
they can i'm sorry daisy
i never should have tried to stop you
from murdering malik all those years ago
daisy has a conversation with cora who
tells her that sybil said there's no
future
in which daisy lets her sister fight
alone and this makes the character
realize what she must do
so far sybil has been predicting their
every move because
well let's face it they're so bloody
predictable
they'll always work as a team and try to
spare lives where they can
instead of ending them this line of not
letting her sister fight alone
makes daisy realize that she must
actually fight without her as it's the
one thing that sybil won't be able to
predict
and thus she goes rogue bumping into
susa on the way
souza also famously never leaves his
post so her getting him to do this and
go with her
will go above sybil's projections so
that she can beat the chronocom's plans
mack realizes they're right and with a
little mac and cheesy lines
he decides to join the group elsewhere
deke tries to do a die hard on board the
zephyr
and he even name drops the nakatomi
plaza which is
of course the famous location from that
film this is quickly cut short though
when he's captured by garrett
who sneaks up behind him using his
teleportation powers
although we don't really see fits per se
in the present
we do see the character in flashbacks as
malik dives into simmons's mind
frustrated that he can't go into her
memories he starts to slap her around
but no matter what punishment he puts on
her diana hides fitz's location
they then knock deek out and mae goes to
cora who shuts down the power at the
lighthouse with one punch
this allows sybil to jump into their
computer system due to the electrical
grid being down
and i don't know if it's me but i also
thought this was a die-hard reference
at the end of that movie the villains
managed to break into the safe at the
plaza
because the fbi shut down the electrical
grid and thus
the firewalls around it drop this is
similar to how sybil gets in here
and yeah i kinda took it as an easter
egg for that
sybil's code goes into the machine and
she sends creepy messages like
i know only hunger now i tried seeing if
this was a famous phrase but i couldn't
find anything on it
however if you think it's a cool little
nod to something then
make sure you let me know below on board
the quinjet daisy and mac have a little
heart to heart
and she tells him that enoch told her
that this would be their last mission
the guy must have seen the advertising
for the season and though it should be
sad
max says maybe it's time daisy doesn't
want to leave what they have
but max seems to be ready to reduce
their relationship to
just being phone pals is that a thing
it is now now i think this does tease
that we may be getting an agent of sword
show
with the character but that mack might
not be there
daisy wants to keep working but mack is
up for retiring and taking a break so
let the man live now he picks up on
daisy and souza having a thing
and smiles because yo-yo owes him twenty
dollars
i wish i'd taken that bet too because uh
we've been shipping susie since day one
and
let's be honest with a lockdown i could
do with the money
i also love how matt gives the what are
your intentions talk to susa
and it reminded me of when souza was in
community as well
and britta found out that he was a war
criminal however they also drop
another cool little marvel easter egg as
mac refers to him as the man
out of time this was also steve rogers's
nickname
and both he and souza were in love with
peggy carter
souza was the loser in that situation
but it's nice how he's sort of become a
reverse of that character
going to the future to be with daisy
while steve went to the past to be with
peggy
souza is shocked to learn that daisy is
called quake
and let's just say she rocked his world
am i right now to be fair it is it is a
stupid nickname
now back at the zephyr malik angered at
simmons being unable to give up the
location of fit
dives into her mind in order to get the
info
it's pretty much an inception but
simmons warns malik that the more he
tries to get the info
the deeper it will be buried it's at
this point that simmons drops a line
about fitz coming to her rescue
and i do think that that is how the
character will finally arrive in the
season
he will no doubt be angry that she's
been kidnapped and this could make him
show up mess up malik's plans and pretty
much
ruin everything for the chrono comes
like how he did in all the other
timelines
we watch as they go into a memory that
had gemma enoch and fitz
discussing going to a temple they also
begin to build diana
and fitz fitz does his usual huffy this
isn't good enough speech
and you know what you let me down fits i
was excited to see you come back
and you bloody ruined it with all your
huffing as per usual now he does tell
them however that it is possible for
them to put the mission on hold for a
second
and you know just have our life together
it does appear that they don't
however i actually think that they did
and that they've used something such as
the blood work that's mentioned to delay
their aging
now the blood work could also have
another meaning and
in real life it's typically used during
pregnancies
thus the time they're seeking may
actually be there to give them the
opportunity to raise their child
together as their child is not with
simmons
it must be with fit and who knows we
could be seeing deek's mother very soon
i'll talk about this more in just a bit
but i do think that the show has been
hinting at it ever since simmons said
they'd spent a long time together
building the time machine at the start
of the series
and who knows we could be getting a new
character for the finale
at the lighthouse the agents tried to
shut down sybil but it doesn't work
and she frees the prisoners namely
durant who as we know has
lee's power to summon blades he goes to
sneak up on yo-yo
but she captures them and during this
korra is freed
coulson shows her that malik and the
chrono comes are causing chaos
and the fact that they're saving killers
it pretty much cements that they're the
bad
guys cora kills duran showing that she's
up for putting things back
but that they would have to make
sacrifices like susa in order to fully
correct the timeline
yo-yo asks for one of the names on a
kill list and she gives up grant ward
ward was of course a member of the
agents that was revealed to be a hydra
spy
ward was raised by john garrett and he
became a love interest of both mei and
daisy
before being outed as a villain colton
states that he's just a child now
and that without garrett he would become
good cora says he would actually be
worse without him
and it does make you wonder whether it's
better the devil you know
it's at this moment that may brings up
jai ying and
i didn't even realize that korra wasn't
aware of her mother's death
korra initially thinks that her mother
can just heal her way out of it
but as her neck was snapped she'll be
unable to come back from it
may tells her that malik was the one who
did it and that jaya ying
died protecting daisy korra has a
complete breakdown and lashes out at may
and the two get into a fight but garrett
arrives and teleports korra to safety on
the zephyr
now i do think that korra will be the
undoing of malik
and now that she knows the truth and has
been sent to him
she might even be the one that ends up
killing him i'll discuss this
more in the preview part of the video
but cora is gonna have to make a tough
choice between a sister and the villain
and i think due to learning about their
mother she will go more towards the
former
back in simmons's mind we see the pair
in a completely white room
this may be something that's devoid of
space and time and thus
they will have had time to grow all
together and potentially
raise their child gemma jumps off the
chamber table
and goes over to deke who asks about
fitz but gemma seems confused
she utters the haunting line fits who's
fits
and i bet it's not the first time
gemma's woken up and not known the name
of someone she's slept with
am i right ladies we'll have no sexism
here girls
girls just want to have fun too now at
the base colton finds the last thing
that sybil looked at
which just so happens to be a bunch of
shield bases we then realized that malik
didn't go into space to hide
but he actually went to call in
reinforcements the chrono comes arrive
and malik murders someone for calling
him sir
and you tell you what mate you bloody
deserved it don't ever assume
anyone's gender pronouns especially in
this new world you scumbag
now from space they destroy all the
shield headquarters
and i love how the plan this entire time
was to just
shoot stuff with a laser from from outer
space
it's it's pretty much becoming like a
james bond villain plot at this point
the triskelion is of course amongst
these targets
and it looks like the mission for the
chrono comes this entire time might have
actually been to create shield
get them all in one place at the same
time and blow them
all up take that kevin feige yeah
make winter soldier make sense now
that's what you get for saying agents of
shield doesn't matter
in the post-credits stinger malik
watches over the destruction
and then sees cora who he kisses after
thanking
she doesn't seem that into it and yeah
sisters before misters
i think is definitely gonna be in full
effect here now we will be talking about
the preview for the finale
so if you don't want anything ruined
then this is your time to duck out of
the video
if you're still here thank you for
sticking around and in the preview for
the two hour epic
we don't actually get that much given
away but daisy does say
this is the last mission together isn't
it it's crazy to think that this time
next week
there won't be any predictions part of
the video and we will be ending the
entire thing without any new episodes
or seasons to talk about from here we
cut to sybil telling the agents that the
war is over
and that they've lost however with fitz
being the key to defeating the chrono
comes
it is possible that he will be turning
up to take them out
the agent support the ship and daisy and
malik go head to head which as i've said
i think will lead to cora
stepping in and saving her now in
addition to this
an eagle-eyed viewer spotted that the
empty chairs look like everyone had been
snapped away
chloe bennett actually responded to this
and said it does look like that
which probably means that it isn't she
might not care about ruining a career
though
now that everything's over anyway i'd
obviously love to hear your thoughts on
the episode
and what you think will be happening
next time comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and if you
missed our analysis of the other
episodes then make sure you check them
out after this
every month on the 15th we give away
free blu-rays and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning the mcu
infinity saga box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you